seen all this before but this time is
different what's different about this
oil bust what technology I remember when
I was a high school student my father
came to me and he said look I've got
colleagues paid for you and your twin
brother but I'm getting out of the
drilling business I can't make any money
on three dollar oil they found all the
oil they're gonna find anyway yeah and
that was years and years ago so frakking
the technology of horizontal drilling
all of this is new and really remarkably
significant for America's energy
security I saw a sobering brilliant set
of charts this weekend on Oklahoma
earthquakes there's no question there's
more earthquakes can you link that in to
the oil system of Oklahoma I think what
what could cause that is wastewater
disposal that could be the cause and
there's a in-depth study going on what
how we get under let's initiative
fracking well I mean fracking itself is
not the issue no forcing water through
rock its wastewater disposal pumping it
into these caverns if you will but we're
disposing because we use it for fracking
yeah and there are technologies now to
use the water without having to pump it
down in the water in the ground which is
something you may have to do because
obviously fresh water look at California
is hugely valuable today and if you can
save it save it till you book within
this we've got to get on this right now
would you agree with that steps annoyed
yeah did Oklahoma you know you get fat
years in lean years in an oil economy
that Oklahoma prepare for the lean years
yeah because we have a balanced budget
and it's not fun I mean when you're the
recipient of the lean years that's not
fun because we have needs and Oklahoma
like 35 states in the Union do produce
oil and gas so everyone is going through
some measure of this but the reality is
generally speaking diversify your
economy generally speaking save money
for the lean years and most states in
the energy patch do it's the saving
money it's it's above and beyond
balancing the budget you have to have a
kind of sovereign wealth fund as a state
to prepare was the money saved as well
yeah that's right okay most of those
states do Oklahoma does but not a great
yellam is not Singapore so you know
those are issues that have to be
addressed but diversification is usually
important and this
is really hurt to see a decline in oil
prices by 50% governor Keating do we
need to lift the export ban yes what's
the argument for it well the argument
for it is there are a lot of things that
we make we find and we produce and we
ship out and why don't we ship out
petroleum products whether it's natural
liquefied natural gas or other products
I mean we ought to do that obviously
there's the argument we don't sell it
all to the Chinese but the reality is
there are excess capacities and excess
supplies out there that ought to be sold
for the right price